まあ最終回で あの えっと
一応あのまあ日本語のタイトルは裏表はないということで
まあ少々内容が変わりますので
まあ私はタイトルちょっと変えたんですが
Ultimate Freedom というのはもう最終的な最高な自由ということで
それで Even Mind というのは
この平安な感情の波立たない心っていうことなんですね Subtleties
この Subtleties という言葉はあまり英語でも使わないんですけど
このもうあらゆるこの隠れているいろいろからくりがないということで
まあほぼ上と同じ意味なんです
はい それからこの今までの講義をね
ちょっと復習してもらわないと
まあ難しかったかもしれませんしね
まあ内容はそんなに難しい内容ではなかったんですけど
まあだいたいまあ 小学生
中学生あたりの人にわかるようにということでデータ並び替えているんです
で  第1番目で あの 言ったのはこの意外と気づかない人の本音というね
ことで 我々は自分の本音っていうことには気づかないんだと
それから人には裏て 裏と表っていうのはあることは常識ですよと
そこで一般的には裏と表が別々で
なんとなくちょっと格好悪いように思ってますよ
そういう それが私はなくしてほしいんです
人間には裏の考え方があって
表にも別なことを全く正反対なことを言ったっても
それが格好悪いんじゃなくて
それが普通なんです 社会の秩序
平和 調和 マナーなどを守る目的の裏と表の差異は正しい
それも覚えてほしい で
心の中で別な考え方あって
口で別なことを言う しかし
口で別なことを言うのは
社会の平和を守るためなんです
秩序を守るためなんです
社会のマナーなんです
だったらそれはしょうがないでしょうね
例えば自分がすごく腹が立ったりします
誰かについて でもそんなことを言ってはいけないんだから
そこでその雰囲気がね
悪くなる可能性もあるし
だからまあそれは言わないで
別に何か他の言葉を言ったりする
その場合は裏と表が違うでしょう
例えば精神的にちょっと弱い人がいるとします
しかし その人はがんになったとします
それでもう家族は知ってますね
この人はちょっと精神的にはまあ耐えられないんだと
で 家族は知ってますよ
がんになって末期状態でもうもう先はないんだと
でもそれが言えますかね
言えないでしょうね だから本人の心の状況を心配して
穏やかにいてほしいと思って
裏の気持ちは言わないんです
だから そうやってこの平和であるならば
調和であるならば 秩序であるならば
裏表は決して悪くないんです
で 相手を騙すための利のみ目指す建前は罪です
それでわざと相手を騙す
自分の利益のために で
不倫しているのにあらゆる工夫してそうしてないとか風に言ったりするとかね
そういうのは明らかに罪なんですね
社会の平和を守るんじゃなくて
社会から自分が不正的ないろいろ利益を得ようとしているんです
利益で言ったっても 物質的なことだけではないんですよ
みんなと仲良くしようということも利益なんですよ
だからみんなと仲良くするために
ありこともないことも何でも言って人を騙しちゃうんですね
で 裏の気持ちは違うんです
そういうのは罪として扱うんです
だから前にいた 3行目に書いたものは罪ではありません
その人は社会のことを大事に思って
人々のことを大事に思って平和を守ろうとして
本音は言わないということですから
それで心を育てない人の本音と建前の同一化はとても危険なのです
そこで時々 もしかすると常識
一般社会では本音と建前が一緒だったらありがたいなと思っているでしょう
でも私が言うのは それはありがたくないんだよと
もし本音建前の間で差がないと
これ結構危険なんで 特にこの精神的に病気な人々で
もう何の理屈もなく犯罪を起こす人々とかは
本音と建前がないんです
殺したくなったら殺すぐらいのことで
盗みたくなったんだから盗んだと
社会のことは考えません
私たちは盗みたくなっても
やっぱりそれがやばいと
社会人としては良くないんだと
ということで もうやめるでしょうね
そうすると裏と表があるでしょうね
裏は盗みたいんですが
表の心では盗まないことにする
それで我々は常識な人間やと言うんでしょうね
盗みたくなったとたんに盗んじゃうと
もう裏と表がないでしょうに
これが社会体とはとんでもない迷惑なんです
はい で  3番目に行きます
これ  2番目の講義で言ったのは
あなたの顔はいくつあるのかということで
そこで私は説明したのは
この裏と表の問題ともう違う側面があるんです
私たちの人格って何なのかと
私は何者かということは
仏教からは言えないんだよと
ぐるぐる変わっちゃいますよと
私たちは だから人には決まってる性格はありません
私は怒りっぽいとかね
私はいつでも欲張りとかね
私はすごい優しい人だよとかね
そんなことを威張っては言えたものじゃないんですよ
誰でも だからそれは私たち
このブッダの真理だから
じっと自分の真理として覚えておけば
結構立派な人間になりますよ
だから私たちは何やるかというと
勝手に自分でレッテル貼るんですよ
私は怠け者だ あるいは頑張り屋
あるいは正直者だ もう何とかレッテル貼って
もう見え張ろうとする
でもそれは成り立たない
ある時は頑張るんだけど
ある時は全くの頑張らないで怠けてしまうし
あることではすっごく怒るんだけど
あることではものすごくニコニコと笑って優しくするし
だから私たちの性格っていうのはこの決まってないんだ
しかし傾向性は存在する
まあ傾向性もありますよ
怒りっぽいとかね ちょっと欲張り的なとかね
ということは傾向性であって
それは何が傾向性というと
このフリークエンシーというのは何でしたっけ？頻度はちょっと高いだけなんです
ちょっと一日中怒る頻度はニコニコと笑っている頻度よりは少々あると
我々怒りっぽい人やと言ったりはする
だからその人は怒りっぽい人ではありませんよ
それは傾向性なんです
その場でその場で人の性格が変わる
そんなのは当たり前で
皆様がこの教室にいる時の性格と
外に出てる時の性格は全く変わるんです
電車に乗ったらまた性格変わるんです
で 家に戻ったらまた性格変わるんですよ
同じ性格ではございません
だからなんか面白いんですよ
私たちっていうのは人間なら動いてるでしょうに
動いてると自分の性格もじりじりじりじりと変わっていくんです
だから自分がどこに座ってるか
どこに立ってるかということによっても性格が変わるんですよ
大阪にいるか 東京にいるか
名古屋にいるかとも性格変わるんです
同じ性格じゃないんです
例えば今花とか咲いてる時期だからね
散歩をすると一歩一歩気持ちが変わって性格が変わっていくんです
満開の花を見たら楽しくなったり
そこでもう酔っ払いとかいっぱいゴミをもうもうすぐ束ねて
もうもうすごく乱暴で失礼な言葉で言って遊んだりしちゃうと
ちょっと気持ちが悪くなっちゃうし
その時は怒りでね なんでこんな人々はこんなをするのかという感じになっちゃうし
いろいろ変わっちゃうんですよ
ただ散歩してるだけでも
だから人間の面白いことっていうのは
この移動すると この動きと一緒に性格が変わる
それはスペシャルなことで
でも時間的にも同じなんですよ
時間がずっと変わってるでしょうに
それと同時に自分がもう性格的にも変わっていくんです
だから時空的に私たちの性格は変わっているんですよ
私はそれを簡単に書いたんですから
その場で その場で人の性格が変わる
それから条件によって我々が演じる性格を定めてしまう
これちょっとややこしい
だから性格は変わるんだけど
なんとなくどこかで定めているんですよ
例えば花が満開の木を見たらニコッと笑ったり
楽しくなったりする 決まってるんです
そこでものすごい酔っ払いがもう上半身裸でものすごい乱暴な言葉使って
もう隣の人にもいろいろ手を出したりしちゃうと
もう決まっていて 嫌な気持ちに怒りになるんですね
で 電車に乗って もう満員電車に乗ってたら
後ろから人がドーンと入ってきて
自分の足を踏んだならば
もうかなり痛いでしょうし
その時すごく嫌な気持ちになるとかね
笑わないでしょ その時は
ああ 楽しかったとかね
で まあそういう風に何か決まってるんですね
どんな場面でどんな性格になるのかっていうことは
なんか我々ははっきり言って機械みたいなもんなんですよ
あるいはこのスクリーンには何もないでしょうに
しかし スクリーンがこのプロジェクターからいろんなものを映すたびに変わっちゃうでしょうに
まあそんな感じで もう
でもスクリーンにはね
私はこの色が嫌だと そこはできないんですよ
映ってる色で決まるしかないんですね
だからこの 性格っていうのは演じるんですから
結局はね なぜ演じるかって
それは本物の自分じゃないんですよ
嫌な人を見たら怒ったんですけど
それは本物の自分というわけじゃないんです
自分で聞いてみたら いえ
違いますよと 私はあの場面で怒っただけですよと言うんだから演じてるんですね
だから演じる性格を定めてしまう
しかし 感情で定める役柄ではなく
理性を保つと良い役も演じられる
これを覚えてほしい 我々は定められている役を演じるんじゃなくて
それバカバカらしいんですよ
例えばゴミを見たら ああ
嫌だ 見たくもないんだっていうことがもう決まってる役なんです
逆に考えると別な役を演じると
このゴミはどのようにリサイクルできるでしょうかとかね
何かこのゴミなんか減らす方法ないんでしょうかとかね
別なアプローチもできるでしょうに
例えば歩道を歩いているところで
みんな横に自転車止まるでしょ？すごいマナーが良くて
人が歩いて困りますからということで歩けないように
それで腹が立つんですよ
それが決まってる演技
役柄なんですね そうすると
これをちょっと横にしておけばみんなに楽ではないかと
ちょっと自転車をね 横にしておく
そうすると別な役なんです
私は北千住にいた時はよくやっていたんだから
もう歩けない 自転車ばっかり
あっちこっち細いところで行きますからね
全部固めて ちゃんと綺麗に整理していくんですよ
しょうがないだからもう
だからこの役柄は自分で変えられますよ
美味しい食べ物を見た途端
ああ 美味しい そう食ってやるぞという風に朴念仁を食っちゃう
それは決まってるんです
その役は あまりにも美味しい食べ物を見ると
見るともう手が出ちゃうんです
よだれも出るんです それは決まってる
演じで豚も同じ役をやるんですよ
だから我々には美味しい食べ物を見ても
別の役を演じてみる まあ美味しく見えたっても
人っていうのは適度知って食べるべきでしょうと
何か別な役 それは自由自在で考えればいいんだからね
私が言う例は唯一の例ではございませんので
皆様何か別なこと あるいはこういう料理方法っていうのはどのようにするものでしょうかとかね
この盛り方は私も勉強した方がいいのではないかとか
という風に別な役も演じられますよ
決まってる豚の役ではなくて
だから私たちはだいたい決まってる役を演じるんだから
ほぼ同じ 犬も猫も豚もカラスもみんな同じ役をやってますよ
カラスでもいじめたらもう攻撃するでしょう
じゃあ人間いじめたらどうでしょうか
攻撃するでしょう だからこちらでいうのは
人間には理性というものがあるんだから
理性を使うと別の役を演じられます
それが素晴らしいんですよ
それで心が自由になっちゃって
いろんなものを創造力が出てきて
いろんなアイデアがいっぱい出てきて
結構人生楽しくなるんです
だからこの複数の人格を持ってる我々はもう多重じゃない無数人格なんですね
この無数人格を持ってる我々はこの
この決まってる人格とか役柄ではなくて
違う役柄を演じてみる
それだけでも人間の心がすごく自由になって
いろんなものを考えられる人間になって
アイデアに溢れてインスピレーションに溢れて生きていられることができるんです
はい で また進むんです
良い役を演じるとは それで良い役を演じるということは
もうちょっと仏教的に説明します
自分の利益 それから相手の利益
それから一般的に 皆の利益を考えて行動することです
だから食べ物を見た途端
じゃあ食べてやるぞということではなくて
この三原則で考えてみるんですよ
考えてどんな役を演じようかなと
そうなったら 人間の生き方というのは本当に素晴らしい生き方になるんです
ただ ゴミはポイ捨てとかなんとかなくなっちゃうんです
で 他の人はもうものすごくマナー悪くゴミを捨ててあっても
なんか自分が見たらすぐじゃあこれ整理してあげましょうと
それは皆のためになるんだから
別に自分が損するわけではないし
それで本当に立派な人間にはなります
それが良い役なんですよ
まあ私には良い役を考えられませんよとおっしゃるならば
これブッダが推薦しているこの役を演じてほしい
この役を演じて何かでも間違いは起こすのかと
誰にも起こしません 自分も損しないし
周りも損しないし 一般的に社会も損しません
それだけでもやれば 世界のこの無駄遣いっていうのはどれほどなくなると思いますかね
人間には使いきれないほど資源がありますよ
全部もう無駄遣いしているんだから生きていられない
あのイラクでくだらないことに使ったお金は
皆様の年金でも増しちゃえばどうなるんでしょうかと
もともとあんなものを潰さないでいたならば
だから我々はそうやっていろんな無駄なことをやっていて
自然破壊している それでこちらも一生懸命苦労して儲けてるお金をまたあのおらかな人々にあげなくちゃいけない
もっと無駄遣いしなさいと
だからそういうのは誰がやっても罪なんですよ
だからこのお釈迦様がこういうちょっとしたことで
一人一人が まあこれ変えればね
それしか答えがないんですよ
ただ 悪い人が根絶していれば
世の中無駄遣いなくなって良くなるんではないかと思ったって
これはありえないでしょうに
例えばこれから日本もものすごいお金払って
国内的にもいろいろ警備やらなくちゃいけない
なぜかというと テロを起こしてくれとも大きな声で頼んでいるんだから
まあ起こらないと私は一応楽観的には見ていますけど
でも政府にはそういうふうに楽観的にはできないでしょうに
ただ 東京の中で警察を動員することにもどれほどお金がかかると思いますかね
自衛隊とか なみじゃない
私一番困るのは なんでゴミ箱までないのかと
ゴミ箱にあの段ボールで閉めたんだからでテロなくなりますかね
まあ頑張ってくださいとしか言えないです
でも皆様の税金が無駄になってるんですよ
皆様の年金がそれで切られちゃいますよ
消費税も上がりますよ
皆様別に何も悪いことしてないよ
何も悪いことしてない
談合したりとかね 落札をいろいろ裏でいろんなカラクリやったりとか
そういうこと何もしていないのに
こちらが罰を受けなくちゃいけないっていうのはね
まあとにかくそんな政治の話はどうでもいいんですけど
まあ一応まあそうそれがなくならないんですよ
悪しき悪い人間が世界からもう全部根絶するというのはありえない話ですよ
だから私たちは一人一人こういう生き方をすると
悪い人は悪いことをしなくなるんです
私たちはイスラムの人々にも悩みをね
ちゃんと真面目に聞いてあげれば
平等に扱えば悪いことしないよ
だからまあ 私たちは良い役を演じる場合は
一応こういう三原則でやるんです
普段は嫌なことに怒るに決まっている
好きなことに喜ぶ これ欲なんですね
欲に決まっている 嫉妬
何でしたっけ？恨み 悲しみ
悩み 高慢なども決まってるパターンで起こる性格なのです
決まってるんですよ 例えば嫉妬っていうのは
自分にも何かがあって
他人の方がもうちょっと上なんです
嫉妬するんです 試験を受けたりします
二人で 自分も合格しているんですけど
向こうの方が点数が高い
それで嫉妬するんです
それはもうパターン決まってます
一度でも合格した人が落第した人に嫉妬はしませんよ
これはありえないんです
美人がそれ美人でない人には嫉妬しません
逆です だから決まってるパターンです
恨みもそうなんでしょうし
自分のことを心配してくれると恨む
その人のことは全然恨みません
ちょっと自分に嫌味言ったら
言われたら 自分もちょっといじめられたら
ちょっと無視されたら恨むんです
だから恨みっていうことは
自分の尊厳にちょっと指さしたら恨みが出てくる
それそういう風にこの法則的にパターン決まっている
他は説明しなくていいと思いますけど
決まってる性格を演じ演じないで
反対の性格を演じるのです
これも一つのブッダからのアドバイスなんです
反対を演じてみましょう
例えば 自分は美人だと思っていたんだけど
まあちょっとどこかである人に会って
自己紹介して友達になった人が結構美人
そうすると決まってるパターンは嫉妬することなんです
それ反対のことをやってみます
嫉妬しないで その人のことは評価する
素晴らしいですねとかね
なんて美しい方でしょうかとかね
素直に喜んでみれば 嫉妬の反対は喜ぶことなんです
そこで自分が試験はもう落ちた
友達は合格した 嫌な気持ちになるんです
それは決まってるんです
逆をするんです 友達のことは本気で喜ぶ
祝福する それでこの決まってる役の反対を演じてよ
それ簡単ですよ だって決まってることはすぐ心に入るでしょうに
いきなり嫉妬が湧いてくるんだから
すぐこれが嫉妬だ だから逆を演じるんだぞと
これが怒りだ 逆を演じるんだと
例えば高慢なんかは高慢というのは相手が自分よりはいろいろ能力がない
自分の方が上やと思った時は高慢なんですね
その時は高慢の反対 謙虚ということ
そんなことはないんだと
みんな同じだ それを心の中で演じてみる
そういう風にこの逆を演じるということで
結構心の修行にはなります
そういう方法というのは全て具体的で
必ずいい人間を作りますよ
やってみれば パーセントの確率性で
はい で 番まあまあ同じタイトルですから
怒り 憎しみ 嫉妬などの代わりに慈しみ
欲の代わりに奉仕など
逆の役柄ですね それから常に落ち着いていることも効果があります
もう一つなんです 常に落ち着いている
合格しても落ち着いている
試験が落ちても落ち着いている
人に怒鳴られても落ち着いている
褒められていても落ち着いている
落ち着き性格も大体すべてのことに機能がありますよ
今 嫉妬だからどんな役を演じればいいのかとわからなくなっちゃうでしょうね
大体今怒ってるんだから
私は怒りの役じゃなくて
どんな役がいいか分からなくなっちゃうと
落ち着く 落ち着けという役を演じてみるんです
落ち着いていますよと
それは大体どんな役にも効き目がある役柄なんです
これ悪役とした方が良かったかもね
決まってるパターンの役は悪役で
その代わりの良い役を演じると
それから理性を保つこと
常に人間というのは理性を保った方がいいんですよ
それから善悪行為に注意すること
個人個人で私は悪を犯したくないし
善を行いたい人間であるということは自覚して生活する
そこら辺になってくると
ちょっと仏教的にもなりますけど
それから優れた人格を目指すこと
それもいい案ですよ これは全部提案なんです
反対の役 どのように演じるかということで提案です
それを覚えた人 覚えておいた方が必ず役に立ちます
これで 3番目の講義なんですけど
その講義の省略です 良い役を演じることに人は努力するべきというのは当たり前の事実です
しかし それで前言ったでしょう
良い役を演じましょうと
悪役をやめて でももったい何か足が引っ張られることがあるんです
それは 3番目の講義で説明してたんです
それは良い役を演じる人に限るんです
例えば皆様方 この 5番目のスライドで言ったことは
真剣真面目にやろうと思っちゃうと
こちらでこのハンディが入ってくるんです
それはこの巧妙な騙し機能ですね
心に この講義がすごく難しかったんですね
なんかわけわからなくなっちゃって
講義 1.25やりましたけど
それで良い生き方を実行することを心の騙し機能がすると
心の騙し機能が働き出すのです
せっかく自分がいい人間になろうとすると
自分の心の中で騙し機能というものがありまして
それが働き出すんですよ
騙し機能にはこのワンチャカという専門用語があります
仏教では 意味は騙しっていうことなんです
しかし 人が人を騙すんじゃなくて
自分の心が自分の心を騙すんです
だからすっごいタチが悪いんです
わからないんです ワンチャカとは他人を騙すのではなく
自分を騙すことです ですから
個人の力では決して発見できないとも言えるのです
なんで曖昧で書いたんですかというと
この断言してそこら辺は書けないんです
お釈迦様は我々には一人一人の出家にこれ騙し機能が機能するかしないかということは
自分一人一人でチェックするように教えられているし
それでも騙されますよ
自分の心に ものすごい巧妙なんです
もう偉い大長老でもつい騙されたということもあります
だから良い人間になろうという人にのみ入ってくる攻撃なんです
悪人には関係ないんです
人が立派になればなるほど
騙し機能が結構牙を見せて騙すのです
だからこの発見できないとも言えるの
できない言える 必ず発見できないというわけでもないんです
しかし もう無理と思った方がいいんですよ
自分が騙されているのかということは
はい 正直 正直に他人に親切にするしたくなる
これは騙し機能の説明で
次 正直という説明しました
しかし これは騙し機能の説明です
しかし 自分も気づかず
相手を自分の仲間に 味方に
自分に依存する者にしたいという気持ちが隠れている
これは一つ例なんです
騙し機能の 初めは自分が正直にこの人に助けて
その人を助けてあげましょうと
この人の面倒を見ようと思って
正直に人に奉仕するんですよ
でも自分知らない 本当の心の無意識の狙いは
その人は自分の味方になってほしい
あるいは自分に依存する人間になってほしい
この夫婦関係で女性がやりますよ
それが 旦那も子供も必ず自分に依存するようにと一生懸命奉仕するんです
苦労して でも本人はいい母親で頑張っている
いい奥さんで頑張っていると真剣にとは思ってます
でもどこかで自分から逃げて行ってはあかんとということで
逃げられないようにとするんです
それわかってるんだったら騙しじゃないんですよ
この連中逃げて逃げて行ったら私は寂しい
だから逃げられないようにするぞという企みならば
騙し機能じゃないんです
そこは微妙なんです わざわざ企んでやってるんだったら騙し機能じゃない
自分知ってる でもそれ知らない
正直に尽くしてると思っている
でもこの機能が入っている
2番目の例 他人に徹底的に奉仕する
相手がいっそうその恩恵を感じるように司る
自分の宗教に入信してもらいたいという欲が隠れている
これはかなり外国の我々の第3世界でこの NGO がやっていることです
ものすごく嫌われてるんです
自分の国だったら NGO と言わない方がいいんです
すごく無視されるんです
そこまでもう NGO なんでボランティアして嫌われるんでしょうか
もうバレバレですね しかし
本人たちがどうか分かりませんだけど
一生懸命奉仕して 私は知っているある一つのケースなんですけど
村のみんなに教育させてあげるそうと
で ちょっとした一仮のなんかもう学校みたいな塾みたいなものを作って
そちらに無料で教えると
言うと もうみんな子供たちをそちらに入れるんですね
それで子供たちを教えて
まあ一回 二回 一週間 二週間
二 三ヶ月とかんとこ で
子供選ぶんですね 選んでもあなた方すごく頭がいいんだから
もっと街とかね 都会とかコロンボとかそこら辺にいて勉強しましょう
奨学金あげますよと子供を持っていくんです
で 母親も誰も知らないどこに連れて行ったか
別に子供に何か悪いことするかどうか分かりませんだけど
それであの両親がそっとその組織に依存していなくちゃいけないんです
それで宗教に依存しなさいと
そうすると 子供はなんとか何とか教会
なんとか何かいるんだから
あんた方は入れませんよと
子供に会いたいんですかね
だったらちゃんとした信者でなければいけないと
あんた信者にならなかったら
あんたに永久的に子供に会うことはできなくなるんだよと
知ってるケースなんです
それははっきり言えば誘拐なんですけど
誘拐としても扱えないんですよ
だって外国団体でしょうし
もうヨーロッパやらすごい力あるし
それだったらあのやわやわしい政府を脅すし
警察にでも頼んで調べちゃうと
政府そのものを脅しちゃうでしょうね
まあ自分の国と違って
もうイラクはどうでしょうかね
あれほど大きい国でももう粉々に潰すでしょうね
だから黙ってなくちゃいけない
だからまあ そういうふうなことはよく起こるんで
だからといって この NGO に参加する若者が
初めからもうそういうきったない気持ちで入ったわけじゃないんですよ
若い人はだいたい気持ちは正直ですよ
何とかしたいと この我々は贅沢ばっかりしていて
これは良くない だから一年
二年 三年とかね こういう貧しい国々なんかに行って
一生懸命ボランティアして入った方が自分にとってもいいんじゃないかという本気で入るんですよ
入ったところでああいう風になってしまうと
だからもう気合入れちゃうと
知らないうちにダムスキーの方が働くんです
はい で また また一つ例なんですね
社会では何一つもうまくいかない
社会人として成功を収めることを諦める
修行の世界を選んで悟りを目指す
その人は しかし 社会に対する怒り
または自分に対する怒りが隠れている
本人知らない  仕事をしてみてもうまくいかなかった
結婚してみたらうまくいかなかった
仕事は転々と変えて変えてみた
なかなかもう相性が良くない
合わない 肌に やっぱり私は修行した方がいい
で 修行に入る 正直ですよ
その世界で もしかするとそれが私の居所かもしれませんと言って入る
でも本人わからないのは
社会に対する怒りかもしれません
あるいは自分に対する怒りかもしれません
それが いい例はオウムに入った若者たちなんです
本当に正直な清らかな心で入ったならば
あんなことできるはずがないでしょうに
あれほど狂暴になって
だから本人たちが社会に対して勝手に怒っているんです
親に対して  [背景音楽]それで親と喧嘩しないで
万引きもしないで 銀行強盗もしないで
宗教組織に入って心清らかにして修行するぞとやるんです
やがて行動は反社会的な行動をする
しかし いまだに気づいてない
自分たちが未だに立派なまともな人間だと思っている
だから直すこともできない
これを知っているならば
そういう人々に簡単にカウンセリングできますよ
あんた方は我々みたいに朝から晩までもうもうごちゃごちゃ仕事をしながら酒飲んで
もうふざけて悪いいろんな悪いことしている人間よりあんた方は悪人だよ
修行なんかやってるんですけどということは
本当はあんた方は気づいてないだけですよ
我々は社会でろくなことをやっていないと認めていますよと
でもあんた方はそれもしていないでしょうと
だから大人に言えますよ
私たちは完璧ではありませんと
仕事をする上で 家族を守る上でいろいろ悪いこともしますよと
人を騙したりもしますよ
会社のために しかし 私たちはやっていることは
まあ悪いこともやったなと知ってるんだと
あんた方はどうでしょうかということですよ
そういう人々にする必要なカウンセリングは
で もう一つもうわかりやすい
これも単なる例だけで
こういう例で この騙し機能はいかに巧みかと
いかに巧妙かとわかってほしい
それだけのことで 別に誰も批判しているわけじゃないんです
単純な福祉活動をやり遂げたマザー・テレサが
ノーベル賞だけではなく
教会から聖人ぐらいも聖人格もにも認定されたでしょ
現代珍しいケースなんです
昔の人々は聖人 聖人 現代人の中でね
極めて珍しいケースなんです
まだカトリック教会っていうのは
まあ大体もう百年ぐらい経ってから聖人確認決めるんです
それくらい厳しい組織がすぐ決めちゃったんですね
ということは すごいでしょう
マザー・テレサの活動は
それに惹かれて自分も福祉に人生をかける
ある人 これは仮定の話である人がやっぱりすごいと
じゃあ私も福祉に人生かけるぞと思う
思った時点で本人の心の中で名誉欲が隠れているんです
あの名誉欲で惹かれているんです
でも本人知らない 福祉こそすごいと言っているだけ
まあそれぐらいの例で
この騙し機能っていうのは
いかに我々の足を引っ張っているのかと覚えてほしい
こういう問題があるのは
良いことをしようとする人間だけ
それを覚えておいてください
だから一番最後に書いたこの社会奉仕しましょうと人生かける人が良いことをしようとしているんですよ
それで騙されてしまうんです
はい まともな人間になろうと慈悲の実践を始める
気持ちが正直なので 次から次へと人生は好転する
本当にこの慈悲の瞑想を真面目に始めると
みるみるうちに人生は好転する
それでよかったと よかった
とことん実践するぞと決める
そこが問題なんです すごくややこしいんです
それが欲に欲が隠れています
慈悲の瞑想をやるならばとことんやってほしいんですよ
慈悲の瞑想 正直な気持ちでとことんやると
もう決まって人生は好転する
もう見事に奇跡的にいい人生になる変わるんですよ
そこでちょっとした引っ掛けが起こるんです
なんて素晴らしい瞑想でしょうかと
もっともっとやれば もっと人生は好転するのではないのかと思ってしまって頑張るんですね
その時は慈悲が汚れているんです
欲で 人はあなたは本当に信頼できる人だ
真面目に修行しているのだと自分を褒める
言われた本人は本気になってそのように励む
これよくあるんですよ
あんたすごく正直ですねと言うと
本人がやっぱり正直にならなくちゃと頑張るんですよ
あんたすごく優しい人ですねと褒めると
相手は言われた相手がやっぱり優しい人間にならなくちゃいけない
もっと厳密に優しい人間にならなくちゃいけないと頑張るんです
真面目に しかし 慢 疑 欲
どちらか隠れています
その場合は これ大変ですよ
はい 自分の心に騙されてでも行っていることは良いこと
これは騙し機能の発見方法なんです
決して騙されている人が悪いことをしませんよ
援助の人々も悪いことはしませんよ
そういう貧しい人々に家を作ってあげたり
いろんなことをやってます
だからやってるのは悪いことじゃない
それなりに良い結果も出ますが
見事な完全な成果は得られ難いんです
そこがポイントなんです
自分が真剣に頑張ってますけど
結果はそこそこ 例えば慈悲の瞑想の場合わかりやすいんですよ
初めて慈悲のことを聞いてびっくりしちゃって
やってみようではないかと
私もあまりにもするがしこいだから慈悲の徳は言わないんです
ただ単にすごい論理的に
これこそ人間の道ではないかと言ってやらせてもらうんです
なぜかというと 正直にやってほしいんです
知識人として インテリ人として
そうやってみると 自分でも理解できないいいことばっかり起こるんです
そう起こると まあだからやりなさいと言いたくて
私は待ってますけど なかなかそういうケースが出てこないんです
まあそれはまあ それの瞑想などではよくわかります
最初はいい結果が出るんですよ
正直でやっていると それからとことんやるでしょうに
毎日分しかやらなかった人は時間やるようになったりする
あるいは暇があるたびにやるようになったりする
なのに前ほど結果がない場合は
もう自分の心が綺麗じゃないんだよという証拠なんです
だからボランティアしても福祉しても人助けしても
あまり自分の努力に適した結果がない場合は
心の方が騙されている
それでしか発見できる方法はないんです
良いことをし続けると
本気になって無心でやる気になることがあるのです
その時は騙し機能が消える
それも覚えてほしい別なポイントなんです
良いことをしようと頑張る
頑張っていると 何のことなく無心になって
まあしょうがない やらなくちゃあかん
もう自分でもう始めたことだからということで
自分でまいた種だからっていうことで
別に何も気にしないでもうずっとやる
その場合は騙し機能がないんですよ
だから 初めて騙された人でも
途中で騙されなくなります
例えば あのあまりにも人々に褒められて
あなたは信頼できる よく修行もする人やとか
全然修行もしてないお坊さんに言っちゃうと
あなたなら信頼できますよと
そんなに真面目に修行しているんではないかとか言われると
お坊さんはやっぱりこれまずいんだから
じゃあちょっと真面目にやろうではないかと思うかもしれません
でも真面目に修行を始めると
それ騙されてますよ でも騙されて始めたんだけど
途中で本気になる可能性あります
あの信者さんのことはどうでもいいやと
まあこれはもうとてもいいことだからやらなくちゃって
そこで始めたらまた騙される可能性もあります
だから騙すたり 騙し機能が消えたり
また騙されたり また騙し機能かかったりとかね
むちゃむちゃなんです
この瞑想 ヴィパッサナー瞑想する時でも
騙し機能かからないように指導する
これすごく大変です ものすごい疲れるんです
指導する側は いつでも騙される
いつでも本人が本人に騙される
それにもこの中途半端でやる人じゃないんです
真面目にやる それで騙されちゃう
騙されるとまたそこを直してあげなくちゃいけない
で また真面目にまだ騙されちゃう
ずっとあるんです この騙し機能がなくなるレベルまで上がったら
まあ 1時間 2時間でもう悟り開けるんですよ
そこまでこの機能が頑張るんです
この騙し機能 だからこれは仏教の世界でもものすごい難しいところです
一応今日はわかりやすい例で説明したんだから
それで覚えてほしいんですが
それから最後の行は真面目に無我の気持ちで始めたが
途中で騙し機能が入る場合もあります
騙し機能で始めて途中騙し機能消える場合もあって
騙し機能がなく始めて後で騙し機能が割り込む場合もあります
両方もあります はい 次に行きます
したがって人は良いことをしても純粋な気持ちにならない
行為は完全清らかとは言えない
しかし 行う人は汚れた行為をしたくはありません
心の騙し機能を見破ることも至難の業なので
それは一般的な考え方で
誰も汚れた行為はしたくないでしょうし
清らかな行為したいしね
でも誰にもできないんですよ
完全な清らかな行為 だから我々のどんな行為でも
結果は大体中途半端なんですね
なんででしょうかと私たちは悩んだりするんですけど
こんなにいいことをしているのに
なんでこんな結果なのかとは悩んだりするんだけど
問題は自分がやっているいいことそのものが汚れているんですよ
でも本人は汚れたことはしたくない
でもわからないうちに汚れている
発見もできない それで自分は心何者かと自覚する必要が出てきます
だから我々は心って何者かと自覚してほしい
でないと大変なんです
自己紹介できれば騙す機能に打ち勝って完全清らかな人間になれるのです
ということで 自己紹介する必要が出てきます
自分が何者かとわかってほしい
はい  4番目の講義に入ります
で 自分と向き合うということ
隠れている または認めたくない本当の自分っていうのは心ですね
発見しなくてはならない
我々は自分が正直だと思ってはいるが
実際正直を演じているのです
あの正直論は延々と喋りましたから
この前 4番目だからね
あまり時間経ってない
正直ということで 本当は正直ではありません
本当の心の状態とはどのようなものでしょうか
我々の本当の心ってどのようなものでしょうか
ということ それからコピーなんです
この前の講義の コピーだから
またちょっとややこしい
難しくなりますけど 自分にどうやって How do we meet ourselves? 我々は私
私は私にどういうふうに会えばよろしいかということで
それであのステップ 4つで説明しましたけど
1番目はあっちを抜かして
この 2番目からコピーしています
だから前読んだ同じものなんです
心は完璧ではありません
何でも正しく知るわけでもありません
私たちの心は完璧でもないし
知る機能ですけど 正しく知るわけでもありません
基本的には無知という感情で機能している
心の基本的な感情は無知なんです
だから正しく知恵が生まれません
それに欲と怒りが加わります
無知にその上またひどいことで欲と怒りも粘りつくんでしょうし
我々知っているのは欲と怒りだけですけど
それが無知に粘りつくんですよ
本来の心は不浄なものです
強者ではなく弱者なのです
心っていうのは強者じゃない
ものすごい弱いんです
それは本物の自分の心なんです
はい 進みましょう で それでまたセカンドステップで
これは前の 20番目のスライドです
弱者の故に隠れようとする
だから心は隠れたい隠れたいばっかりなんです
なぜかというと弱いんだからなんです
隠れて強者演じるんです
弱者でありながら自分を管理している
従って人生はいつも納得いかないものになっている
心が弱者でなのに この弱い者が心を自分を管理しているんですよ
だから弱い者に管理されると
もう納得いかないでしょうに
頭の悪い政治家が政権取っちゃうとかなり大変でしょうに
例えば軍隊の司令官にいる人が臆病者だったらどうしますかね
無茶苦茶でしょうに 納得いかないでしょう
だから我々の司令官である心が臆病者で弱いんですよ
だから我々の人生っていうのは無茶苦茶で納得いかない
何をしても で  2番目に心は本来正しいものではないと知っておきましょう
2番目ってなんだ  1番が
まあ 2番目が今のところ好きかもしれませんだけど
我々はこれを理解して
心っていうのは正しいものではありませんと
そうすると結構いいんですよ
自分の心はダメですよ
正しくないんだよ と知った方が安全なんです
全て問題解決しますよ
それだったら はい で それからやり方なんですけど
自分を発見する 自分 悪を発見する
まずは悪を発見する いくらでもありますから
心は本来不浄だから難しくない
これは 我々一日中やっていることの 9割以上は悪い悪ばっかりなんです
だからいくらでも発見できます
しかし 心の騙し機能が働くからやる気にはならない
悪を発見したくないんです
あれ 騙し機能があるんです
例えば真面目に修行しますと言った人に
私は仕事はしたくない
俗世間には溺れたくないとかね
出家しますと真面目に言った人が
あなた何か怒っているんじゃないの？と言ったら
これは怒られるでしょうに
私もカンカンみんなにたまに怒られてるんだから
これはその人の心にある騙し機能なんです
私もそれなりに理由があります
理由ではなくて 自分もまああまりにもこのストレートに物事を言うんだから
このストレートで物事を言う社会ではないでしょうし
でも私にとってはもう間接的に生ぬるくは言えないんです
仏教というものは ブッダはストレートになりませ
なりましょうという話だから
だから私もその 何て言いますか
受難を受けなくちゃいけない
すごい受難なんですよ
だって自分にももう誰よりも上手に人を騙せますよ
人の機嫌取ろうと思ったら
これはもう握りだ と思います
だって心の働き全部勉強しているんだから
そんなこともない でもそうだったら本当のこと言えないんですよ
昨日ある人から手紙もらったんです
いい文なんかこの私の先生の先生のような顔をして
で 読んでみたら このすごい侮辱されているんです
で ダンマパダから偈二つ入れて
どこから取ってきたのかわからないんですけど
人のことを批判するなよと
神仏を批判するなよと
ということで まあそれは言ってもいいんですけど
一つ言いたいことがありますけどというふうにあった方がいくらか常識的なんで
私は批判受けますよ 人を批判する人はね
人に批判を受けなきゃとんでもないことでしょうに
でもまあそれがなくて
いきなり偈を入れて そちらは粗悪語というか
言うなよと言ってるだけのことで
それはどういう意味かというのは私はよく知ってますけど
だから本人知ってるのかと
私は原文で読んでるんだから
それはどうでもいいんですけど
で まあ人の神仏を批判するなよと言っても
それ成り立たない なぜかというと
理性っていうのは知識っていうのは比較したらわかりやすいんですよ
私は慈悲のことを教えると
他の宗教でも慈悲について何語っているのかと調べて言う
だから当然その場合はどちらの方が正しいってことを言わなくちゃいけないでしょうに
大学の論文じゃないんだから
こういうふうに考えるのではないんではないんでしょうかとかね
それはできませんだから
私は例えば聖書にイエス様が人間のみを愛するように言っている
また俺を愛しなさいとも言っている
自分のことを愛さないと気持ち悪いじゃないですか
常識的には だからそれを言っちゃうと
仏教では一言葉でもブッダをブッダに慈悲しなさいと
ないんだよ 私のことを放っておけと
あんた方が私のことを心配するならば
自分で修業しなさいよと言うでしょうに
だから比較するとどちらがいいかっていうことは明らかでしょうに
決してこれは相手の宗教を侮辱しているわけじゃない
相手が侮辱されたというふうに感じるかもしれませんだけど
その場合は相手も反論しなくちゃいけない
私の悪いところは あまりそういうところと喋ってないんですね
みんなほとんど仏教ばっかり教えてる人々だから
だから反論が出てこないだけで
そういうところに行ったらちゃんと反論は受けます
だからこの難しいんですよ
わかりやすくしようと思って比較したところで
なんてことを言うのかと言われると
やっぱりその場合でも事実を知りたくないということで見え張るんですね
私はあなたよりは人間できてるんだよというね
できてるはずがないんで
誰でも このお釈迦様おっしゃっているプロセスで心清らかにしない限りはもう清らかにならないんですよ
人物神仏を拝んでも それでお釈迦様がこう言ってますよ
お祈りして期待叶えるならば
人類はみんなお祈りばっかりしなさいよと
お釈迦様それ侮辱じゃないんですか
他の宗教に対して だからそうなると私は引用できなくなっちゃうんです
それで私はその人に反論出してないんですよ
自分一人で反論を出してみたんです
私が聞きたいのは なんで自民党はもう一つ
なんでしたっけ？民主党？民主党を批判してはいけないんですかね
民主党も政党であって
自民党も政党であって
どちらでも国民に向かって私に投票しなさいと言ってるでしょうに
その場合は自民党が民主党ではなくて
自民党に投票しなさいと言ってるでしょう
もし自民党の方々は 神様も皆様素晴らしい方で
大変正直で真面目で 国のことは真剣に愛してますよと言っちゃうとどうなるんですかね
もう成り立たんでしょうに
だからいくらなんでも仏教も私は宗教ではありませんと言っても
世界から見れば宗教でしょうに
だからあの宗教は素晴らしい
この宗教素晴らしいということは
宗教を語る人としてはできません
一般の方々にはあれもあれ
これもいいやということは言えます
専門家には言えないんですよ
だからまあそれは侮辱には入りません
侮辱っていうのは 批判するということは
尊厳を貶すことなんです
あなたのやり方は本当に間違ってますよというのは侮辱じゃないんです
あなたはけしからぬ人間だよと言うと侮辱なんです
あなたやってること本当にけしからんだから
もうちょっといい加減にしてくれないのかというのは侮辱じゃありませんよ
だからまあそういうことで
この例えば皆様方はそんな関係ないんだから
ただ殺害しただけで で
真面目に自分の悪を発見しようとしちゃうと
自分でも気持ち悪くなっちゃって
もうやる気にならないんです
なんで気持ち悪くなるのかというと
私はそんな悪じゃないんだよと自分で思っちゃうんですよ
そんな悪じゃないんだ
あの時怒っても 本当は別に私は嫌です
怒るのは だからそんな悪じゃないんだと自分で思っちゃう
それが騙し機能なんですよ
そう思っちゃうと この実践をできなくなるんです
だから 真面目にヴィパッサナーやら観察システムやろうとしても
自分の心が騙そう騙そうとはしているということを覚えておいた方がいいんです
はい たくさんありますから
早く行きましょう また同じことの続き
ステップ欲 怒り 怠け 嫉妬
我がまま 落ち込みなどの自分にわかる心の悪を発見して認めていく順番があります
だいたいまずそれぐらいわかりますから
まずそこから始める 自分を何て言いますか
良くしようという努力はこの場合は要りません
ただ認めるだけで十分です
これが悪だ これが嫉妬だ
これは怒りだ 今怒ってるんだぞ
今落ち込んでるんだぞとかね
それだけなんです 落ち込んでわかん
落ち込んでわかんって言ったら
もう騙し機能が働くんです
落ち込んだらあかんじゃなくて
落ち込んでいるという風に確認する
良いところもあるのですが
とりあえずそれを後回しにするということは
どんな人間にも良いところありますよ
でもそれはそれほど量がないんだから後回しにしましょう
大量にあるのは悪の方だから
それをまず確認していくんです
良いところ確認してしなくたっていいんじゃないんですかね
大体成長する人は自分の貯金
収支 何て言いますか あればっかし見ているんじゃないでしょ
毎日 これぐらいお金あるんだ
これぐらいお金あるんだとか
バカバカしいでしょう
毎日頑張ってどれぐらい入るのかと
ないことを見ないと金持ちにならんでしょう
だから心の場合でも同じ法則で
もう悪を確認していくと
まあ善もあるものだから
それはまあいじめない
いじめる必要はないんです
で 悪が減っていって で
善で満ちていくんだからね
はい それで 4番目のあれで
悪を正直に認められる勇気を持つ
勇気持たないとできんです
少しちょっと弱いんだったらね
なぜか なんでそんなこと私は言いますか
この心理学では そんな人が犯した悪とか
それは忘れるものではないか
それは認めてはあかんではないか
それでさらに落ち込むんではないかというふうな考え方あります
この俗世間の心理学ではそれではないんです
我々は堂々と勇気を持って認める
そうしちゃうとしっかりした人格が出てきます
だから勇気は必要 客観的に物事を判断する
それから判断能力 それでも客観的に判断する
悪は勝手に減っていかない場合は
場合なんです 悪を確認しても
客観的に判断しても それでも自分が悪だったらどうしようかと
怒り これが怒りだ 今怒っているんだぞと言っても言っても
怒りがなかなか消えてしまわない
そういう時だけ自分の良いところも確認する
その時だけ確認するんですよ
確認して あの粘り強い怒りを追い出す
私にも結構いいところあるんだよと
で 思い出しちゃうと あの弱みがなくなっちゃうんです
悪を善で置き換えることを試す
その人は悪を善で置き換えることを試すんです
はい 今自己紹介のところ
それで自分は何者かという自己紹介ですね
あらゆる感情が混じり合って自分が生きている
私たちはいろんな感情が混じり合って生きているんです
自分の性格を定めるのは難しい
私の性格は何なのかということを定めることはできない
ごちゃごちゃ変わるんです
その時の条件によって反応する
普段我々はただのあの食べ物
美味しい食べ物を見たら
まあよだれを垂らして食べてやるぞと思うだけであって
もう同じ その反応するだけのことではないか
えーと 気づけば決まってる反応を変えることもできると
それも覚えて それも自己紹介なんです
もし私が気づけば あの豚の感情は出さないんだと
豚 豚も演じる犬も演じる
同じ役ではなくて 違う役も演じられますよということも覚えておく
それから自分というのは悪に落ちやすい
なぜならば 心っていうのは無明
無知でできているんだから
簡単に悪には誘惑されますけど
善にはそう簡単にはいかないんですね
かなり難しい それが自己紹介です
それは自分と向き合うことなんです
はい それで 条件によって自分の心が変わることと
そのシステムが分かったところは
自分が自分に出会ったことです
ここら辺になってくると結構難しいんです
それでずっと自分の悪を確認しながら
悪が出ていかない場合は善に置き換えたりして
それから理性で物事を見たりしていると
だんだい分かってきますよ
美味しいご飯見ると食べたくなっちゃって
お腹が減ってくるんだぞとかね
ゴミなんか見てみると気持ち悪くなるんだよとかね
しかし 花を見ると気分が良くなるんだよというふうに
このシステムが見えてくるんです
なんだ その時その時の反応ではないかと
それが自分を自分を発見したことなんです
そこをできれば ダメな機能をかなり管理できます
はい まあほとんど終わったとは思いますけど
これ今日のテーマになります
で 裏 裏と 裏と表のないサツンの世界
ずっと喋りっぱなしで喋るのは簡単で
聞くのは簡単じゃない
と言っても私ちょっと疲れたんですから
ちょっと5分ぐらい休憩します
えーと あの心の葛藤っていうのはありますからね
だってあの本音とね 建前っていうものあるんだから
常に裏と表 本音と建前は対立している
まあ大体これはみんなにあるんだからね
それで精神的な混乱と苦しみのそれはね
原因になりますよ だからどんな人でも結構大変でしょうね
だから裏と表っていうのはほとんど違うんだから
これお互いにぶつかり合ってるんですよ
例えばもうすごい 何と言いますか
嫌な客が店に来る 見ただけで嫌な客だなとわかるでしょうに
でも自分が店やってるんだったら
ペコペコと親切にしなくちゃいけない
何を言われてもニコニコとしなくちゃあかんでしょう
これで結構大変でしょ
心の中で だからずっと我々はあらゆる苦しみをね
例えば子供はなんとかとんでもないことをしたとする
それでもやっぱり我慢強くそれを見守っていなくちゃいけないとかね
かなり大変です だから
この裏と表のこの対立のおかげで
我々は結構大変苦しんでるんです
しかし 簡単には消えません
これ簡単にはそれでも消えません
逆に消えたら困るという現状もあります
裏と表で一つでも消えちゃうと大変でしょう
逆に考えると だから消えたら大変犯罪者になっちゃうし
精神的にイカれてる犯罪者になっちゃうんです
だから消えても困るし
あったらろくろ人生はできないんです
裏と表の差があると毎日神経質でストレス溜まって疲れて悩むこといっぱいあって生活しなくちゃいけない
大変ですよ あっても困るし
なくても困るという ではどうすればっていうこと
で 建前を本音と同一させるか
だからやることで答えは建前と本音を同一同じものにするか
本音を建前にするか  2番目は危ないんですよ
それどちらかなんです
しかし あるのは これわかりやすく言えば
A は B にするか  B は A にするかってことなんです
しかし  A と B の組み合わせは良くない
いわゆるごちゃ混ぜで
A と B とごちゃ混ぜは良くないんです
A は B にするか  B は A にするか
どちらかなんです でないと
本音と建前は消えません
けれども皆この配色廃炉の人生なのです
ごちゃ混ぜにしてはいけないのに
我々は混ぜてるんです
だから時々本音も出るでしょう
そこで本音が出たところで大変なことになったりもする
大体人間っていうのはいい人間か悪い人間かと言ったって答えがない
大体灰色でしょうに だからそれはもう私たちは本音と建前
結構ダブっちゃったりして
時々出ます 建前と本音が
時々というか結構出るとかね
会社では随分建前出るんですけど
家に戻った途端本音ばっかり出るとかね
ありますよ で 結婚するまですごく親切でしたけど
結婚してたら何のことなく
すごい精神的な おかしい人やとというケースもあるでしょう
だから家に戻ったらもう本音が出る
お互い仲良く恋していた時は本音は出さなかったんです
デートなんかしている時はすごい建前で
女の人はそれを見事に騙されますからね
だから先にぶっ潰しておいた方がいいんです
本音と建前 2つありますよと
はい で 問題点 本音は悪なので表に出せない
まず本音っていうのはね
建前は一時的だから それを本音にすることはできない
でしょ デートの時はすごい品格よく
紳士の紳士らしくレストランで動いたっても
毎日死ぬまでそんなことできる
だから建前というのは一時的なんです
会社ででも社長がなんか突然来たら
大きい会社なんかの場合みんなきちんと決まって挨拶をして
大変背筋を伸ばしているでしょうし
ずっといられますか？それで一生いられないでしょうね
その人いた途端 またごちゃごちゃ喋ったり
もうふざけたり 仕事をサボったり
いろんなことをするということだからね
だから本音だけでもダメでしょうし
建前持ってくることもできない
両方合わせて生活すると
優柔不断 混乱 落ち着かない
不安 不満というのは出てきます
これは耐えないんですね
一緒にしちゃう どんどん疲れて遅くなっているんです
それがまあお釈迦様の解決策なんです
本音を清らかな状態に磨き上げる A
はBにする BはAにするところじゃなくて
本音を悪でしょ それはしっかりと磨き上げる
善に そうすると心配することはない
本音がバレてもバレるものないんだから
じゃあ続けます なぜ？まあ
ちょっと説明にまた入ります
なぜ本音が存在するの？っていうこと
心は本来無明アヴィッジャーなので
物事はありのままに認識してない
心っていうのは本来何も知らない状態でいるんだから
ありのままに認識しないんですよ
我々の認識は個人の主観であり
普遍的な真理ではありません
それは簡単でしょ 私たちはもう認識するっていうことは自分の主観なんです
花が綺麗とかね 今日は暖かいとかね
そんなのは普遍的な真理じゃないんです
したがって 自分が知っている
経験している世界は自分だけの世界です
これすっごい仏教ではものすごい大事なポイントなんですよ
花を綺麗っていうのを言語的にはみんな使ってますが
実際自分が綺麗に見た花は他人にはそういう風に見えません
別な見方なんです なぜかというと
頭の中でそれは現象化するんですよ
花っていうのは頭の中である現象なんです
音楽っていうのは頭の中である現象なんです
隣から聞いているのは綺麗な音楽だなと思っちゃうと
皆様の気持ちがそちらに行くんです
でも みんなそう思わない可能性もある
それはわからない 個人個人で
だから知識世界は全て主観なんですよ
残念なことに これで私は人のことを批判するんだと言われたってもしょうがないんです
すべての知識世界 知る世界は主観であって
普遍的な真理ではありません
で 他人と共通性も薄いし
コミュニケーションもそれほど成り立たない
だから私はものすごく孤立して孤独なんです
私の気持ちは誰もわかってくれません
これは明確に前に説明しましたから
この前の 講演で で 私はご飯見て
あ このご飯美味しいですよ
食べてくださいと言っても
相手に経験させることはできませんよ
この間子供はなんか子供食べるお菓子いっぱいいろいろあるでしょうに
それで私に持ってきて
はいどうぞと 私はあれは好きじゃない
甘いし それで一人が同じものをもう一人の子供持ってきて
同じものでしょう たくさんでしょう
いえいえ これはすごく違いますよと
これの味とこれのこれは結構違いますよ
だから子供にとってはものすごい味が違う
同じものなんですけど
大人から見れば 大変な美味しいことなんですけど
だから子供は自分たち味わっている喜びを私にも味わわせようとするでしょうに
でもこれは不可能なんです
私ははい ありがとうとカバンに入れたままで
1ヶ月とかもそのまま忘れちゃって
食べるところから それは私の世界でしょ
そんなもの食うもんかと
だからコミュニケーションというのはなかなか成り立たないんです
はい 同じことで なぜ本音が存在するっていうこと
したがって 人は安全でしたっけ
安全のために心を本音と建前として分離するのです
我々は自己安全のために分離するんですよ
これが精神的な病気の原因ですけど
ということは 自分だけの世界でいるんでしょうし
相手が別な世界にいるし
そうすると相手が じゃあこれインド人と日本人で比べてみましょう
インド人というのは生ものは食べません
で すごい大きな外国人が入るホテル以外は
生野菜はそちらが出ますけど
一般的には食べません
何でも料理して食べます
それでインドの偉い人がこちらに来たら
日本の偉い人は豪華な料理をいいレストランに連れて行って接待する
日本で豪華と言えばもう生物ばっかりでしょうに
これまた魚がそのまんまで口を開けたりとかね
だから日本の接待する側から見れば
本当に腕を振って 結構真剣に真面目に相手に一番いい接待している
インド人どう見ればいいんですかね
あの場合は 本当は私はそういう経験がありますから
私は真ん中だからどちらの気持ちも分かりますからね
向こうはすっごく気になって
もう心の中でも鳥肌が立ってるんですよ
それで私にごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃいろんなこと言うんですけど
私はまあそうなんですけど
こちらの文化ではこれは究極的な接待だと
みんな必死でやってるんだよと
だからあなたは適当に食べられるものは選んで食べてもいいということで
それでインドの方はまあいろいろ話をそらしたり
他の話をしたり いろいろ褒めてあげたり
まあいろんなことを言いながら
まあなんとか食べられるものだけ食べて
それで話に夢中になって
日本の方々にとってはあれを見るともうもう手がもう止まりません
だからどんどん本人が食べて
一応終わりますよね お金払う人はね
それを無駄にしたくないでしょうね
自分たちも毎日そんなことをやっているわけじゃないでしょうね
そういうことで建前と本音が成り立つんです
そのケースで考えてください
インド人 には自分の気持ちは言えないでしょう
言えますかね 言えないんです
言うとすごいマナーが悪いんです
相手の気持ちを損なったことになります
だからすごく丁寧に ものすごく美味しかったとかね
ごちそうさまでしたとかね
日本の食べ物って本当に面白いですねとか
美味しいですなんて言わない
でも相手が自分の世界でいるんだから
美味しかったね あの人と思いますよ
微妙に言葉だから それ知識人だけの話でね
私の経験というのは かなり金メダル格の教授何人かのそういうことに参加したんだから
そのケースを思い出して言ってます
だからもう頭と言えば大したもんだから美味しいと言わないんですよ
でも向こうは美味しいと言われたように取ってるんです
そういうものですよ だから我々は身の安全のために心を分離するんです
みんなそういうことをやってますよ
だから人間には本音 建前っていうのは初めからあるんです
子供の時からあるんです
子供は何かやりたいんだけど
母親の顔を見るともうちょっとじゃないとわかったら
まあ別なことをして で
ごまかす そういうことで
子供の時からもそれを作るんです
はい それであの訓練ですね
この本音建前を いわゆる本音を磨く訓練ですね
今の瞬間 あるいはのを入れた方がいいんです
今の瞬間の自分を確認する
続けると 全体的に自分を見えてくる
今の瞬間の自分を確認して
それし続けると自分を全体的に見えてくる
智慧が現れて あるのままに見ることができるようになる
それで無明が消えて 他の煩悩も消える
だから自分を確認するとゆっくりと無明が消えていくんですよ
確認するということは
客観的に知ることだから
知ることで知らないこと消えるでしょうに
だからこのヴィパッサナー瞑想でこの無明に攻撃しているんです
怒りと欲に攻撃しているわけじゃないんです
この修行する方々は 私のところみんなもう怒りと欲と戦ってますけど
私は別なんですけど これで智慧に攻撃
無知に攻撃しなさいという話なんです
無知に攻撃すると土台がどんどんどんどん弱くなるんだから
もう上に乗ってる怒りと欲は早くて落ちるんだからね
本音は真理を知る心になって建前がなくなる
結果はそれなんです 本音が真理でありのままに知ることになるんです
無明が消えちゃうんです
そうすると建前がなくなっちゃうんです
それでやっと一つの心になるんです
そこまでは大変苦労しなくちゃいけないんです
そんなところで じゃあ次に行きます
出てこなかったらちょっと押してください
で 自己観察のこの生涯
生涯の自分というのはわからない
なぜ今の瞬間でしょうかという説明なんです
自分の生涯を見たら 自分が何者かと観察できますか？できない
はい 次 年間の自分もわからないんですよ
長すぎてもう忘れているんです
次 年間の自分も把握しがたい
では 私の年間の人生を観察してみるそうと思ったっても
できない ほとんど忘れているんです
では次 だったら 1 日中の自分もどうでしょうかと
1 日中の自分にしたらすごく複雑なんですよ
もう朝何やったかもう忘れてるでしょう
もしかすると昼ご飯何食べたかでもとっくに忘れてるかも
そんなもんです だから 1 日中の自分も観察できないんです
では次  15 分ぐらいの自分ならなんとか理解できそうです
15 分ぐらいだったらなんとか理解できそう
しかし 明確ではない それも明確じゃないんですよ
なんとなくアバウトでですよ
悪いけど だからそれは知恵と言わないんです
はい 次 時間感覚が短いほど自分を明確に理解できるんです
生涯よりは年だったらなんとか言えるでしょうし
一年だったらもっと明確に言えるでしょうし
1 日だったらなんとか言えるでしょうし
15 分ぐらいだったら自分が何やったかと
言えるんですけど ということは
時間というのは短いほど我々はしっかりするんです
だから瞬間という言葉来るんですよ
この理屈わかりますかね
例えば十五分 十五分あげて
十五分でどんな気持ちでいたのかと聞いてよと
なんとなくです それでも
例えば怒っても一日中怒っているわけじゃないでしょう
一日中もう二 三時間怒っていたら
今日は一日中怒っていたんだよというのは
もうあまりにも大雑把
アバウトすぎなんですよ
そんなアバウトで智慧が現れません
だからとにかく時間を短くするわけです
はい 次に行きます えーと
今の一秒の間の自分なら
明確に 確実に 疑いなく
疑問なく 曖昧ではなく
推測もなく 仮定もなくわかります
具体的に なんでそんなたくさん言葉を使ったのかと
それはお釈迦様の真似なんです
だから日本語的に文法成り立ってないかもしれませんだけど
パーリ語ではそういう風に喋るんです
その方がはっきりするんです
今の一秒の間の自分なら明確にわかるでしょ
確認できるでしょ 一秒だけだから
それ確実に 疑うこともなく
疑問も起こることもなく
曖昧の気持ちもなく 推測することでもなく
仮定でもなく 具体的に発見することはできます
発見すること 確認することはできるのです
だから この裏と表をなくして
裏を完璧に綺麗にして表を並べる方法
そのためには一秒の自分を観察するんですよ
そうすると百パーセント正しいんです
今の一秒に怒っていると
今の一秒で落ち込んでいると
今の一秒でこれこれやと
心見るな 体見ることで瞑想始まりますから
もっとやりやすいんです
しかし これがすごい正しいやり方なんです
知るものは百パーセントの確率で知る
かすかにでも推測はしてはいけない
これが怒りかな？ダメです
もしかすると欲かもしれません
そういう確認はダメなんです
確認だから だから初めは怒り
欲を確認させません 歩くことをやら
座ることをやら お腹の膨らみ縮みやら
そういうものを確認させるんです
それから集中力ができて
頭が良くなってくると
怒り 欲とか発見するようにしてください
いきなりはやらせません
それでも難しい なぜならば
修行してない人はできるかなと思いますけど
それも曖昧なんです 仏教にしてみれば
目 科学よりもはっきりと知ってほしい
科学の世界でも六十パーセントのデータあればもうOK出すでしょうに
仏教はダメだ 百パーセントの情報がないと認めない
九十九だったらもうそれは推測に過ぎないです
それぐらい厳しいんですよ
悟りの世界は  次に行きます
一秒も結構長い時間なので
私は一秒で言ったら皆様に分かりやすくさせるためなんです
仏教は瞬間という時間単位で見ることを勧めるんです
瞬間というのは光の速度ぐらい速いんです
その単位で見てくださいと
まあできそうもないと思うでしょう
できます どんどん瞑想して
心を集中して集中力を育て上げると
妄想がどんどん減っちゃうと
もう心はその自分の本来のスピードで見るんです
その時は瞬間瞬間で見えるんです
その時はもうすぐ完成しますから
修行は はい 次に行きます
それでちょっとあの心の説明なんです
本当は瞬間の自分に裏も表もないんですよ
あの瞬間の自分には 今までずっと裏と表の話をしたんですけど
実はないんです その説明なんです
別に裏を育てて表を追い出すこと必要ないんです
もともとなかったんです
これはどういうことかというと
心っていうのは瞬間瞬間で機能するんです
上に向いてる矢印と下に向いてる矢印ありますね
上 下を向いてる矢印では
私は本音の心と書いたんです
これで上を向いてる矢印では建前の心
心っていうのは波で 心は絶えず生滅し続ける一本の波として仏教は理解する
なぜ仏教は理解すると書いたのですかというと
この他の宗教を侮辱するなと言われると困りますから
これが真理だと言いたいんですけど
まあ一応仏教はそういうふうに理解する
そこで見てください あの黄色い矢印があの一応これはアバウトで 4つ書いてますね
ということは 別々な心は 4つ 1
つ生まれて これ消えて
次の心が生まれて それ消えて
次の心が生まれて機能します
それは上を向いてるんだから建前
次の心はまた波は下に行って
また 4つ書いてますけど
これ 4つの心って意味で
これは本音のところ それからまた建前で
それからまた本音で また建前で
また本音でとかね そういうふうに時間が流れるんですよ
しかし 今の瞬間でこの 1個の心しかないんです
それはかなり修行しないと発見できません
しかし それ発見できるまで瞑想すると成長しますよ
これが何でそんな だから本音
だからこの これは本音のところで
これは建前 それは大雑把な言い方なんですよ
心が下を向いている時は本音のところで
外の世界を向いている時は建前のところで
だから我々は長い時間とって本音と建前とあるんだよというだけの話で
全く心はこういう風な波で機能しているんです
それは本当に心の本当の働き方なんです
で 悟りっていうのはどういうことかというと
まあこういう上も下も向かない
それは図で描けませんから
一本になるだけ それでもう一つ言いたいことは
皆様方は一人でいろんな妄想したりしてるでしょ
一人でいろんなことを考えたりして
同時に別な仕事もしているでしょ
でもそれは成り立たないんですよ
妄想する時でも時間かかってるんです
時間の流れ だから あ 嫌だと思っちゃうと
もう遅いんです そこ時間になってる
なくなってるんです 嫌だと言わなくても
思った瞬間でも そこはスピード
時間取ってるんです だから妄想する時もかなり時間なくなってますよ
例えば歩きながら今日はいい日だな
気分がいいなと思いながら歩くでしょうに
歩くスピードから時間取ってるんです
ここからあそこまで歩くためには 3秒かかるとします
その間でいろんなことを考えて歩くというと
考えながら歩いても 3秒しかかかってないんだから考えることには時間経ってないっていう理屈でしょ
違うんです 時間取ってるんです
あまりにも心が早いんだから計算できないだけ
それが本読む時やってみてください
本を読む時 いろんなことを考えながら本を読んでみてください
1時間で読める本は 2時間ぐらいかかるでしょう
だからこれわかる人が
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想で私たちはものすごくスローモーションでしなさいと教えてるんですよ
これ真面目にやってみると
誰よりも速くなるんです
妄想が減るんだから だからすっごく時間を無駄にしているんです
まあまあ これでこの心の流れはそういうことで
だから実際は本音建前という 2つあるわけじゃなくて
瞬間瞬間に心が現れて消えて現れて消えていくだけで
時々は内を見て自分のこと
主観のことばっかり考える
時々は社会に合わせて心が機能する
それだけの話 社会に合わせている時は本心はわからなくなっちゃうし
本心に入っちゃうと社会のことがわからなくなっちゃうし
こういう流れで心が動いてます
そんなこと簡単だと思いますけどね
それで生まれてから死ぬまで
そういうふうに行くんです
はぁ 知恵って何なのかって
そういう観察も知恵が現れるんですよ
瞑想すると何がわかるんでしょうかね
何か超能力でも？そんなことじゃないんです
そんな現象じゃないんです
瞑想すると因縁の法則がわかるんです
すべて一時的であるっていうことがわかるんです
執着するべき実体としての対象がないっていうこともわかるんです
一時的な現象を連続に現象の連続に引っかかっていることは無意味だとわかるんです
このシャボン玉に玉を大事にして
何やと バカじゃないかとわかるんですよ
シャボン玉みたいなもんでしょ
生きるっていうことは
瞬間 瞬間 瞬間で消えていく
だったらもうアホ以外は
あのこの人生ありがたいと思わないんです
シャボン玉は綺麗には変わりはありませんだけど
誰も持っていこうとかね
置物にしようと思わない
なぜならばすぐ弾けるんだから
だからそれがわかるんです
それは空という話ですけど
専門用語入れちゃうとね
空ってドッカということで
心が現象に対して諦める
それの専門用語があります
ニッビダという  恩義ですか
まあどうでしょうかね
サン ニッビダですね 諦める
解脱する それで心が解脱するんです
これはもう それは説明できない
どうなるかってわからないんですね
一応 一切のものにはもう諦める
諦めると心はもう人間に考えられない
どんな人にも考えられない状態に変わってしまいます
が まあそれも心は無常だからね
それでも でも輪廻転生はしないとか
なんとか苦しみはすべて消えたとか説明するしかない
そろそろ終わりと思います
はい 次に行きます 結果として
裏と表の永続的な対立がなくなる
これで心は完全に平安になる
常に穏やかな気持ちでいられる
本音と建前がなくなるので
精神的には全く悩みの苦しみはない
今言った方法でやればすべて解決して完全な安穏な状態が出てきます
やってやっと本音で生きていられるのです
成功したならば 何の苦しみもなく
だからお釈迦様なんかは本音で生きていたんですよ
この本音の人が別に自己管理しませんよ
怒らないようにとか全然しません
ただ自然に本音でいる
ある日 お釈迦様に聞いたんですね
あなたに質問すると なんか随分研究なさって
長い間考えて喋っているようなんですけど
本当にお釈迦様一人でいると
人からこういう質問されると
こういう風な順番で答えるぞとか
そういう準備とかなさらないのですかと
いえ 全然ないんだよ ただあんたが聞いたんだから答えただけや
だからお釈迦様はちょっと質問に答えたっても
見事に言葉から何から何でも完璧なんです
それはもう本音の建前がないんだから
ただ言うだけのことで
そこでお釈迦様がお坊さんたちなんかに怠けたりすると
すごい怒鳴るんですよ
でも怒りは全くもない
だから誰にも反論できないんですよ
だからお釈迦様が他宗教を批判しなかったというのはとんでもない話ですよ
それだったら仏教って成り立たないでしょう
批判するところから全部むちゃくちゃ壊されてしまったんですよ
今のヒンドゥー教は仏教を受け取って生き延びているでしょうに
ジャイナ教もど派手に影響を受けたでしょう
だからそのところがキリスト教まで仏教からいろんなことを学んでいるでしょうに
だから他宗教は素晴らしいと言っちゃうと
それで成り立ちません
ある日はお釈迦様はこういうことをバラモン人に言ったんだ
あるバラモン人がお釈迦様にちょっとね
我々はしっかりした生まれが正しく
7 7代目までなんとか何とかで
あなた方は何か頭を剃ってとか言ったら
お釈迦様はなんのことなく
まあその通りだ でも昔のバラモン人はとても良かったよと
言うとバラモン人もああそうですか
と褒めてくれるみたいなと聞いているんですよ
言ったら昔のバラモン人は性的な行為をするためにはバラモン人の女のところにしか行かなかったんだよと
でも今のバラモン人は欲が出たらどんな女とも一緒になるんだよ
でもね 昔の犬は交尾する時はメス犬しかところにしか行かなかったんだ
今の犬もそうですよ 交尾するところはメス犬のところに行くんだよと
それでですね あなた方はね
犬を守っている道徳を守ってないんだよ
犬より衰えているんだとはっきり言うんです
あのバラモン人の丘で
それずっと 1行じゃないんです
それ一つ経典なんです
でもそれは聞く側も侮辱だと思わない
ちゃんとした論理的な説明だから
それでお釈迦様は最終的に何言いたいかというと
生まれはどうでもいいやと
だらしない性格だったら人はだらしないんだよと
それはちょっと辛口でインパクト強く言うんです
もう一つ 昔のバラモン人は女性と一緒になったのは子供を作るためですよ
だからそれは大事な行為であって
遊びには行かなかったんだよ
だから女性が妊娠できる状態になったら
やっぱり子供を作らなくちゃあかんなという感じで
そういうことをしましたと
今はあんたたちはもう遊びでやりたい放題やってるのではないかと
でも昔の犬もメス犬が妊娠できる状態になった時だけ交尾したんだと
発情期になった時だけ交尾した
今の犬もその道徳を守っているんだよと
もう明確に犬に例えるんですよ
なぜならば インド文化で犬といえば結構品格がないんです
だったらゾウも同じですけど
ゾウは使わない その場合は
だからまあ まあお釈迦様も結構そういう厳しい言葉をずっと使っていたんです
だからまあ私はまあそこはばっかし読んでいるんだから
スイスイその調子でしゃべるんですけど
気をつけなくちゃいけないんですね
この世の中ではとにかくブッダが本音で生きている
いたんです 裏表ないわけではなくて
本音で生きている その本音は完璧で素晴らしい智慧の完成した本音なんです
だからお釈迦様の叱りは叱りになりません
時々お釈迦様は質問出されてもう人が落ち込んじゃって
大変なことになった時もあります
お釈迦様は全然気にしない
それはあんたのせいだと
あんたなんでそういう質問するのかと
なんのことかと いろいろ経典を読んでみると
結構もう派手にもう伝道活動をしていたんです
そうでなきゃもう生ぬるい人間がこれ理解すると思いますか？今日のこの 5回の講義を聞いてください
どれほどそれと汝は神様に作られたんだぞというふうな分かりやすい話と比べてみると
こんなのはね 結構きつく言わないと人間はやっぱり聞きたくない
面白くないというか うるさいということになるんですよ
だからかなりきつく 派手にもうぶん殴るような感じで言うんです
それは皆様のことを侮辱しているわけじゃないんです
これそうしなきゃ我々の心っていうのは開いてくれないんです
それぐらいすごいもう無知っていうのは機能しているんです
そういうことで 次に行きます
これで終わりです これちょっとこの方法については釈尊の言葉なんですけど
アヌプッベーナ メーダーヴィ トーカトーカン カネーカネー カッマー ロラゲタッセーヴァ ニッダ メー マラマッタノという偈なんです
智慧がある人は少しずつ
その瞬間 その瞬間 その瞬間
その瞬間で自己の汚れを落とすのです
金細工師は銀の汚れを落とすように
だから瞬間瞬間でいいんですよ
いきなり一発で完璧な人間にならなくてもいいんです
その瞬間で現れる怒りだけ消しちゃえばいいんです
その瞬間である欲だけ消しちゃえばいいんです
そういうやり方でやるんですよ
これはある神霊が二人が会話していたんです
一人がブッダに大変気に入られていた神霊で
もう一人は別に知らない
それで君もブッダに会ったらどうでしょうかと聞いたら
その神霊が随分質問するんです
その人は落ち着いているのかどうかね
その人は罪を犯さないのか
いろいろそこで一つの質問に答えなんですけど
マノー タッサ スッパニヒトー
これは裏表のない心のことなんですよ
彼の心がかなり育て上げて磨き上げて
もう完成しているんですよ
金銀は百パーセント綺麗にしたような感じで
金でも掘るとただの土でしょうに
役に立ちません でもゆっくりゆっくり綺麗にするでしょう
銀もそうでしょうし サッバブーテス ターディノ
これはサッバブータというのは全ての生命というふうに訳しなくちゃいけないんですが
サッバブータっていうのは
言語で言えば全ての物事
現象ということでも言えます
どんな現象にでも平安で平でしっかりしている
まあいわゆる揺らぎない
もう信頼信じてるんだから
全ての生命に対して平安に感情を断つにたどり着いていると
アトー イッテー アニッテーテ
それから好きなものであろうか
悪いものであろうか サンカッパッサ ワシーカタ
それに頭の概念がゆらゆらしないんです
例えば 好きと思うものを見ると心が変わるでしょ
ああ 欲しいなとか 嫌なものいたらあ
嫌だなと変わるでしょ
それがないんです お釈迦様は
裏表がなく ずっともう綺麗に流れているんだということで終了します
次に行きます すみません
では一応まあ五戒の話はそれで終了いたします
えーと いかがでしょうか
何か分からなかったこと等ございますか
これあのインドのガンダーラも彫刻でかなり古いものなんです
仏像はこの説法している形です
昔にはいたいた彫刻も上手でした
何か質問とかあればもうほんのちょっとでも時間があります
あるわけじゃないんですけども 8
時半で もう30分経過したって
もう今は1時間も延びていくんだからね
もう悪い癖がついちゃって
今のお話を聞いてて あの
いわゆるなんかよくマスコミとかで騒がれてる多重人格の人の話ありますよね
あれもあの 別の人格が出てる時の記憶っていうのは一切抜けてて
あの同じ人格が同時にいるわけじゃなくて
なんかもう時間ってぼんぼんぼんぼん流れて
それのやっぱ人間はじゃあみんな軽い多重人格みたいな
誰にでもまあ軽くないんですけど
我々の場合はこの過去を思い出せる
それだけのこと 多重人格症状だという人は思い出せないんです
それだけの問題なんです
例えば 今もう大人でいて
突然子供に戻ったりするでしょうし
多重人格者は それちょっと30分前なのに忘れているんです
つなぎがないんです で
私たちもやっぱりその瞬間だけの人生だから
結局同じことですけどね
時々子供の時を思い出したりして
その気分にいるでしょうに
でもさっさと元に正気に戻ることはできる
差はそれだけ まあとにかくこのいくつかの線で心を構成
合成していると仏教は言わないんです
1本の波で波ですけど 1
本でもない ただ瞬間瞬間瞬間が変わるものだから
縁起ですから はい そこから何かございますか
よし 終了しましょうか
では 本当に5回分けていろいろ付き合ってくれて
本当にこの難しい話にありがとうございます
ということで終了いたします